this has been another week of tough
economic news the federal reserve bank
raised interest rates three-quarters of
one percentage point as it tries to get
inflation under control that's the
highest increase in almost three decades
the major stock indexes wrapped up their
worst week since 2020 and the pandemic
crash for the week the dow lost almost
five percent and the s p 500 finished
more than five and a half percent lower
the nasdaq was off nearly five percent
as well the price of oil dropped
slightly but still remains high michael
george joins us to sort all of that out
good morning michael michelle good
morning we're seeing multiple signs the
economy is slowing and a new report of
leading economic indicators suggests
weaker growth in the near future now
experts say we're not in a recession yet
but we could be headed there
in an economy driven by consumers
economists are keeping a close eye on
what they're up to
take credit cards in may use was up 10
percent compared to last year but
throughout 2021 monthly credit card use
reportedly rose 20 percent on average
signaling slower spending many consumers
are buying fewer goods dana peterson is
chief economist at the conference board
which analyzes trends in manufacturing
housing the stock market even the movies
and issued the leading economic
indicators report friday what's the big
takeaway that they can get from these
indicators the big takeaway is that um
look there's there's trouble ahead
that that's something that we shouldn't
ignore but right now things are more or
less okay most people are working the
unemployment rate which is something
lots of people do pay attention to is
very low it's 3.6 percent and not only
are most people in the united states
working many people are seeing wages
rise a steady paycheck is helping
consumers to keep consuming even as they
pay high inflation driven prices there
are a lot of people who believe we may
already be in a recession can we say
whether or not we're at that stage yet
well the leading economic indicators is
telling us no we're not on a recession
right now but the reason why some people
are saying that is because it may feel
like one
inflation is super high and a lot of
that's being caused by factors that are
arguably outside the united states
russia's war in the ukraine is a key
factor worldwide and one president biden
called out yesterday when he hosted the
major economics forum from the white
house and with russia's war driving up
inflation worldwide
threatening vulnerable countries with
severe food shortages we have to work
together to mitigate the immediate
fallout of this crisis
in the united states
i'm using every lever available to me to
bring down prices for the american
people
and the president also said the u.s is
coordinating the largest release of
global oil reserves in history what he
and congress have yet to put on the
table is lowering the federal 18 cents
per gallon gas tax as some have
suggested dana all right michael people
will take any relief they can get thank
you